everyone this is kevin from the chest
website calm and i just want to tell you
guys the new site has been launched the
chess website calm if y'all haven't
checked it out before you definitely
want to check it out but i did want to
let everyone know about the new site
because i have added quite a few stuff
i've been working on it for the past
month or so a lot of you guys have had a
lot of great feedback for me if stuff
you said you wanted to see on the site
I've tried to put a lot of that on there
there's anything that I am missing
definitely feel free to let me know
because I'm always trying to make the
site better for everyone so just want to
go over a few things that I did put on
there one of the things I've been asked
to put on the side is a section for
basics a lot of people are trying to
teach their friends how to play and want
a place where they can go and basically
tell them hey here's everything you need
to know about chest from the beginning
up so i made this section here basics
and you won't even see this on the
youtube page but it's got a section for
ponds Knights bishops rooks Queens Kings
and opening principles in general that
anyone even if you know how to play
chess you still may want to check out so
it's got a lot of great stuff for
beginners on here if they're just
learning how to play second thing I want
to talk about is the navigation up here
as many all know the last navigation
didn't work on some of the browsers and
it only had about half of the options up
here but now this new navigation has all
the different pages on us you can pretty
much get to any page with one or two
clicks next thing is the social
networking tools you'll see at the top
of the page the tweet this big this
Facebook and stumble upon this a lot of
people been asking how can I share the
site with my friends this is going to be
the best way you can just click on this
one of these however you want to share
and it'll immediately take you to the
page where you can share chess website
calm with other people
next thing a lot of people email me
about puzzles say hey Kevin I can't get
this puzzle up and looking at it forever
as you can tell the first ten puzzles
we're just trying to out trying to get
some feedback from people tell me what
they think but on each of the first ten
puzzles there is now a click for hint
button so if you get stuck on a puzzle
and you can't figure it out you can just
click on this click for hint and a hint
going to show up so I think that's going
to help out a lot of people that have
gotten stuck and can't figure it out
over the weeks i will put hints on the
puzzles later on as far as 11 through 43
but for now first to 10 if you want to
go back if there's some that you
couldn't figure out and you haven't got
the answer from me because you haven't
emailed me you can go ahead now and
check out a hint so if you've been
waiting for that they're finally up
second thing a lot of people been asking
for specific openings I have gone back
and added a lot more openings to the
openings page and I will continue to do
so so there's an opening that you want
to see just let me know and I will try
to add it as soon as I can also a lot of
people been asking for lengthier
descriptions as far as the openings so I
have gone ahead and done that and most
of the openings should have a longer
description in as well as long as the
games before I had three games for each
of them and now you should see six games
so if you want to see some more games
for each opening you will now have the
opportunity to another thing I've asked
then asked for under the famous games
instead of having just famous game
number one famous game number two I've
had a request to have the name so
instead of coming to famous games and
not knowing who's playing now you can
come and if you want to check out a game
by Fisher or Kasparov or another person
that you really enjoy seeing now you can
just simply come here and click on their
name and then watch their famous game
that they played so these are just some
of the things I've added i'll be adding
a lot more in the future also on the
front page you can just click on this
update
right here and it'll actually show you
all the updates that I have added and in
the future I'll actually be adding to
the updates page you can see exactly
what I've updated but there's anything
else you guys want me to add just let me
know I will try to get it up as soon as
possible but I hope you guys enjoy the
new site hope everyone learns a lot and
i'll see you guys next video thanks for
watching